[Music]
web security scanner is a built-in
service for the security command center
premium tier
it can automatically scan for and detect
key vulnerabilities in app engine
compute engine
and google kubernetes engine
applications before deploying them to
production
there are two types of scans you can do
manage skins are configured and managed
by security command center
with an scc premium subscription they're
enabled by default and will
automatically run once a week
results will appear in the scc
vulnerabilities tab and related reports
with managed scans you can centrally
manage basic web application
vulnerability detection
for projects in your organization
without having to involve individual
project teams
if you disable managed scans you can
re-enable them
for this you need the sec admin and
security center sources admin iam roles
along with the sec premium subscription
go to the sources and services settings
page
and enable manage scans you may need to
wait up to 24 hours for the application
to be detected and scanned
custom scans are also available they
provide granular control over how the
scan runs
including additional controls like
scanning from a static ip or using iap
authentication
before you begin make sure the account
you're logged into has the project
editor
the organization administrator security
center admin and security center sources
admin iam roles
to enable custom scans make sure you've
also enabled web security scanner in the
settings page
then to set up a custom scan first make
sure your app is running with a public
url
and ips then head to the web security
scanner from the navigation bar
select a project in the page that
appears if you haven't enabled the web
security scanner api before
you will be prompted to do so before
continuing you are now in the web
security scanner page
this page allows you to create save and
run a scan click
new scan to display the new scan form
add in the url
of the application you'd like to test
you can select authentication options
including needing a google account to
run the scan or using identity aware
proxy
iap works by verifying user identity and
context of the request
to determine if a user should be allowed
to access and for now let's schedule the
scan to run weekly and select the
starting date
you can choose to run scans from a
predefined set of source ip addresses
this gives the scanner access to
applications behind a firewall but might
limit the scope of the scan
the export box is automatically checked
it allows scan results to be displayed
on the security command center dashboard
you can also specify the user agent
which is a web client software to be
emulated when scanning your app
max scan speed queries per second and
risk level
because web security scanner populates
fields pushes buttons clicks links
and other interaction low impact
scanning minimizes requests with the
potential to modify data
click save to create the scan the scan
will be queued and then it will be run
at a future time
it might take several hours before the
scan runs
click run to schedule the scan the scan
is placed in a queue and there might be
a delay before it runs
it can take several minutes or many
hours to complete a run
depending on the system load and site
complexity web security scanner will
automatically crawl your application
following all links within the scope of
your starting urls
and attempts to exercise as many user
inputs and event handlers as possible
the scanner attempts to identify common
web vulnerabilities on these pages
including findings from categories in
the owasp top 10
like cross-site scripting mixed content
and outdated or insecure javascript
libraries
the scan will display a results page
when it completes such as the following
if no vulnerabilities were detected
click the scan name to go to the scans
config page where you'll find more
information about the scan
its history and some controls for
running editing or deleting the scan
you can see all vulnerabilities found by
navigating to the vulnerabilities
dashboard
filter by vulnerability type like owasp
in this case
we have the highest number of cross-site
scripting listings and the
recommendation provided
you can click on a finding to bring up
more information about it if we click on
this cross-site scripting error for
instance a pop-up will display
information about the finding including
information like the resource that was
flagged
how severe the flag is and the
reproduction url
you can also share the scan with your
team you just completed a scan using web
security scanner
you can now set up and run on-demand
immediate or scheduled security scans
for your own application from the google
cloud console
[Music]
you